let's go next to Joe in Chicago we
haven't heard from Joey in Chicago since
May hey David how's it going good how
are you good um so I just want to get
your talk do you think there's any
chance that Donald Trump would resign I
mean I've said before I think if someone
sits him down and it's really getting
bad and someone says you were going to
be removed I think it's possible that he
would but I think that his ego would
make him hold out until the absolute
last possible second yeah for sure the
throw thing he just because you know you
see everything happening and like how
bad it is getting and you know I just
watched one of your videos about all the
GOP people that you know are backing
impeachment yeah and it's like he's
eventually going to run out of
Republican hopefully and then well
remember the story I did was that
there's the idea that if the if the
impeachment vote if the conviction vote
were private Republicans might support
it but it's not private
so actually I think you're gonna see
Republican support is removal yeah for
sure
all right well yeah that's that's it man
thanks a lot for everything that you do
okay Joey and Chicago great to hear from
you